We now have video footage from the January
6th Trump riots in Washington, D.C., which
confirmed that a close ally of radical Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green was not only
there, but he was inside the Capitol building. You
might remember that we previously discussed that
a gentleman named Anthony Aguado was suspected of
being inside the Capitol building. And Ignarro is
a known associate of Marjorie Taylor Green's.
He's a right wing. I guess we'd call him like
a right wing live streamer and activist
and went back in February. CNN asked him,
were you actually inside the Capitol building
on January 6th? He didn't answer. And he said,
you know, there have been videos posted which I
was supposedly filming from inside the building,
but they were really filmed by someone else.
He sort of played coy and didn't answer.
We now have videos of the riot in which it is
clear that O'Gara was personally inside the
Capitol building. In the screenshot that we're
putting up on the screen from Freedom News TV,
you see Seguro highlighted by a red circle on
the left side of the screen, clearly inside the
Capitol building. Now, Acquaro has declined to
comment on this. Marjorie Taylor Green's office
has not yet responded to requests for comment.
But this is now it's no longer hypothesis. It's
no longer speculation. It's no longer theory.
This is a confirmed Trump writer who is also an
associate of a current pro Trump Republican
congresswoman who has been heavily defended
and propped up by the former one term president,
Donald Trump. Marjorie Taylor Green and Acquaro
previously worked on anti-immigration issues.
They've been to pro Trump rallies together.
And I previously told you about videos in which
Marjorie Taylor Green referred to a Gweru as
amazing and as a friend. And as CNN has reported,
Acquaro has called Marjorie Taylor Green, quote,
one of my closest friends. So now we know he was
there and we know that a Marjorie Taylor Green
ally was in the riots. Now, what will the next
question is actually one that goes back to a prior
question that we still don't have an answer to.
Were there current pro Trump members of Congress
who were involved in discussions about the
plans for the Trump riot ahead of time?
Were some of these pro Trump congresspeople
notmerely indifferent to the riots, not merely
supportive of the riots after the fact, but
were any of them actually proactive participants
in the planning of the January 6th Trump riots?
We don't know the answer yet. There are already
investigations into certain tours of the capital
that happened in the days leading up to the
riots. And we're still trying to figure out why
would there be any tours since the capital has
been restricted because of the pandemic. That
doesn't make any sense. So many more questions
remain unanswered, I guess, is the way I would put
it now. The position of the right continues to be.
A sort of conflicting mix of talking points, these
were fake trumpets who rioted on January 6th, but
at the same time we heard from Ron Johnson that if
they were real trumpets, they weren't a threat to
anybody like him because they are patriots
who wanted what's good for the country, which
conflicts with they weren't actually trumpets. And
they also had no plans to do anything wrong except
they did because just being there was a crime.
You know how the right loves to say undocumented,
all undocumented immigrants are criminal aliens
because it's illegal to be here. For them,
being here undocumented is a crime. Why does it
matter what they were doing at the Capitol? Just
forcing your way inside is destruction of property
and trespassing, as they like to say about
undocumented immigrants. It's a crime just to be
there under those circumstances. But of course,
very different rules apply to pro Trump
insurrectionists than to undocumented people
coming over the US Mexico border. So
the next question is, will we? I mean,
it's a question for you. It's a question for us to
think about. Will there be any definitive linking
of these pro Trump members of Congress to the
planning and organization of the January 6th
riots? And there's a lot of speculation on this.
There are investigations going on. And then
the sort of follow up question is, if there are
pro Trump congresspeople linked to the planning
of the riots, will there be any consequences?
Because if anything has become the sort of default
norm in the United States political world,
it's that for many elected officials,
particularly Republicans, because their own
party is unwilling to hold them accountable,
there's just no consequences for things that in
the past there would be significant consequences
for. Let me know what you think. And, of course,
we'll continue following the investigations.